MARTIN OMANDER: Hello.
My name is Martin
Omander and I welcome you
to "Google Root Access,"
the show featuring
actionable startup advice.
My guest today is
Mani Doraisamy,
founder of the
startup Guesswork.
Mani, tell us a bit
about your startup.
MANI DORAISAMY: We are a
machine learning startup
that helps to qualify leads and
increase customer conversion.
We do that by building
predictive intelligence in CR.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Predictive intelligence
in customer relationship
management systems.
MANI DORAISAMY: Right.
MARTIN OMANDER: How
come you decided
to work on that problem?
MANI DORAISAMY: We
found this problem
that the leads from the
internet marketing channel
doesn't convert into
customers very well.
For example, if you look
at real estate agents,
they get like a
hundred leads per day.
And out of the 100
leads, 90 leads
are from internet marketing,
like Trulia and Zillow.
And 10 of them are from
traditional channels.
But the problem is, out of the
90 leads, only five of them
convert into customers.
On the other hand,
out of the 10,
the same five leads convert
in the traditional channel.
So very often, we see
real estate agents
and the small business owners
think that internet marketing
leads don't have
serious inquiries,
and tend to ignore them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh.
And then they got rid of
half of their serious leads,
right there.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
Even though it can
double their sales,
they start ignoring them.
So that's how we decided
to build Guesswork.
So we started building this
machine learning service
that predicts which of
them are serious inquiries
and which of them are casual
inquiries, so that they
can focus on the serious ones.
And we desire to build
it part of the CRM.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So let's talk a bit
about objection handling.
You are selling to CRM
vendors, I understand.
And they are technically astute.
And you talk to them
about machine learning.
Do they ever tell you
that, hey, why should I
go with a small startup
and their machine learning,
when there are big players
like Google, and IBM,
and who knows who
else, is doing machine
learning stuff with
more resources?
Does that come up and
how do you respond?
MANI DORAISAMY: Very often.
So in fact, you can't
compete with Google
on machine learning.
They have years of head
start on machine learning.
Have hundreds of engineers
working on machine
learning every day, right?
So we don't compete with them.
We leverage them.
So we build on top of
Google Prediction API.
Similarly, we build on top
of App Engine, and BigTable
to scale for huge
volumes of data.
So in fact, whenever we talk
about using Google Prediction
API for machine learning,
most of the objections
about technology already
stop from the customers.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, good.
That's a good objection handling
technique, if it just stops it.
So I could see a potential
other objection coming up, then,
with somebody you're selling to.
The customer saying, oh, you're
using Google Prediction API
and Google BigQuery.
Why don't I just do that myself?
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
So our value comes
from the rule engine
that we are built on top
of, Google Prediction API.
For example, think about the
same real estate example.
If a customer asks for an
apartment in Palo Alto,
right, the machine
learning algorithm
can come up with an apartment
recommendation, right?
But then that apartment
could have been sold out.
So the machine learning doesn't
give that intelligence by
itself.
A rule engine which understands
that business context,
and then decides to pick
the next-best alternative,
is very important
for such cases.
That rule engine is our IP that
we have brought into the table.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
And so you're
complementing the machine
learning with the rule engine.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: And you are
good at building rules engines,
because you've been
doing that for a while.
And then there's
something about focus
and the customer
leads there, as well.
Tell me a bit more about that.
MANI DORAISAMY: Sure.
So we always know and talk about
technology, because, I think,
there is part of
the stakeholders who
are interested in-- I mean,
like for example, [? CT1s ?]
in a CRM company-- who was
interested in the value we
bring on in the
technology portion.
But if you have to
convince the business guys,
then we have to talk
about what value we bring
and what business
problems we solve.
So we always talk about how
we want to transform CRM
from being a record-keeping
system into a customer
conversion agent.
That business value is what
convinces the stakeholders
in CRM who are
business guys, right?
Who are focused on solving
a business problem rather
then just a technology problem.
So you have a combination
of both objection handling
for the technology
stakeholders as well as
business stakeholders.
And that's very important when
you look at a target market
where you have
both stakeholders.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
So into a sales meeting,
you come armed with here
is why this is good
for your business.
And no technology
discussion there.
And then when the
technology-- the CTO
and so on, they
kick the tires, you
can tell them that
this is good stuff.
It will hold up.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
So I think it's always about
getting the entry into a sales
cycle where you convince the
business guys about the value
proposition.
And then later on
in the sales cycle
where you talk about how
good your technology is
with the technology
decision-makers, right?
So we have both gatekeepers
that you need to cross.
MARTIN OMANDER: Aha, right.
And either one could stop you.
So you'd better be
prepared for both.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So, Mani, you've been doing this
for a while with your startup
here.
What would your advice be
for other startups building
on somebody else's technology?
And how to think about
objection handling,
and how to handle objections
in sales situations?
MANI DORAISAMY: I
think if you look
at choosing somebody
else's technology,
it has to be always based on how
it adds value to the customers,
right?
Very often, we see people
choosing a technology
because they get
marketing mileage, right?
Typically, there is this
business development guy
who is responsible
for partnership.
And he finds that he'll
get more customers
if you have a big-brand
logo in their website.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, the
logo in the website.
Yes.
I worked for a couple
of startups like that.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
So it's this you
scratch my back,
I scratch your
back sort of thing.
And that's the worst way
to choose a technology.
I think the best way to look at
choosing others' technology is
to find out whether
you would choose
that technology irrespective
of the marketing or sales
mileage you will get out
of the big brand that
provides you that technology.
I think that is the
one that will provide
long-term benefit
to the customers.
And that way you will
win, irrespective
of what the other
company does for you.
MARTIN OMANDER: And you'll be
able to handle the objections
better in the sales situation.
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
And also I think the objection
handling is not just using
somebody else's technology.
It's also about bringing
a complementary strength.
It could be technology
[INAUDIBLE].
For example, in our case, we
bring in that rule engine IP
into the table, right?
It helps because we have
14 years of experience
in building rule
engines already.
During the initial
stages of a startup,
customers don't buy the product.
They buy you.
Founders are the product, right?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
The product might not be mature,
might not even exist, right?
MANI DORAISAMY: Exactly.
So you make a personal
guarantee that you
will deliver the
results, irrespective of
whether you have a
product or not, right?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
MANI DORAISAMY: So I think this
notion of founder to market fit
is quite popular in the
investment community.
Chris Dixon popularized it.
But I think it's
equally important
during the initial
stage of the startup,
because you convince
the customers based
on the founders' strength,
and not just on the product.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Well, thank you for coming on
and sharing your experiences
with us, Mani.
MANI DORAISAMY: Thanks, Martin.
It's my pleasure.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thank
you for joining us.
We hope you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.